You are listening to radio lab radio lab
from [inaudible], w.
N. Y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich is this radio lab,
the podcast today on the podcast,
a story about death incarnate
and incarnate incarnate, I think.
I think incarnate and credit. If that
was Tim Howard, our producer. Sorry,
am I in here yet? No, you're
not supposed to be come in.
You got to wait a story about death
incarnate and the man who no talking could
beat down. Yeah.
Are you in? Yeah, let's me jumped in.
Comes from my producer Tim Howard. But
you're already here. So just start. Okay,
so late last year I took a trip
out to Wisconsin guest one too.
It was like that first weekend of
November when we were out there for the,
for the live show. And I met this woman,
Ann Kez to talk about her daughter.
Gina, do you want to tell me?
Me just like where you're
sitting, what room? Crazy story.
I am sitting in the kitchen of my
home and find the Lac Wisconsin and,
all right. So anyway,
back in 2004 and September of 2004, uh,
her daughter Gina was 15 sophomore,
I remember it was homecoming week.
So they had all activities each day and
dress up days and Jean as a volleyball
player. And one morning she just
starts to feel kind of crappy.
She started getting a
tingling in her left arm. Um,
we thought maybe she had a pinched nerve
or something, thought nothing of it.
Then she goes to a volleyball
game with somebody,
I guess sets the ball to her to spike
and she looks up and she sees two of them
and she doesn't know which is the
volleyball double vision. Yeah.
About a week later she started getting
flu like symptoms. She has headaches,
she feels really sluggish. And
each day she just got more tired.
One of those days she does go
to school, take the PSA sats,
but then the next day she
can't even get out of bed.
They go to the doctor and he
says, wow, it's not the flu.
So we went home and then
she just kept getting worse.
Her arm started to involuntarily jerk. Um,
her speech started becoming
real slurred. Um, she,
her body kind of stiffened up.
Like we'd get her up to go
to the bathroom and she just,
just, it was just really scary,
weird how her body was just stiffening up.
Anne and her husband, John took her
to a neurologist for some tests,
just trying to get down to the
bottom of this, you know, and what,
what is going on with her because
of meningitis came back negative.
Everything else that you're
testing for came back negative.
Were they running out of
things to test for? Yeah,
they pretty much didn't know what
else to do. And a day later on,
a Saturday gene is hospitalized.
And then on Monday when her
pediatrician who had seen her on Friday,
came in and saw her and saw how
much worse she was in just two days.
He was like frazzled, like
what is going on here?
And then something just made
me tell him about the bat.
Pat. Yeah. So this was a month earlier,
Gina and her family, they were a mess.
It was St Patrick's Catholic church,
you know, old, big church, um,
and about was flying around and it
was just kind of bothering everybody.
It would just like land on behind the
altar of the stained glass windows up
high. It just seemed like it wanted to
get outside and there are open windows.
It's like go out there right
there, go. But it just,
and then it would swoop
down and it started getting
lower to the people's heads
and stuff. And there was an
usher, he hit it to the floor.
I don't know what to use,
but Gina kept looking back at
it and being the animal of her,
she is, she thought she had to
help it. And so she jumps up,
runs over to the bat, grabs it by
the wings and takes it outside.
And as she does the bat bites her on
the index finger of her left hand.
So it breaks the skin. Yeah, they washed
it and then thought nothing of it.
But when Anne told the pediatrician
about this, his face turned white.
He walked out of that room,
he says, I'll be right back.
But he never told us what it was. They
immediately rushed her to Milwaukee,
to this other hospital, this hospital,
Wisconsin, to be treated by this guy.
I'm Rodney Bullet B. I am an
infectious disease consultant.
And at the point when Rodney met Gina,
she was a, what we call stuporous.
You mean like she couldn't
talk? She could, but barely.
She was talking only single sentences
could only follow a one step command.
She was in a wheelchair because she
couldn't physically stand and her left arm
with twitch and spasm. She
would apologize, say sorry.
And then try and get back
into position for the exam.
And she was literally getting worse by
the minute. Within two or three hours,
she had to have a breathing tube put in.
She was essentially becoming
comatose the way she looked.
I wasn't sure if she was
going to survive. Uh, and,
and of course, if she had rabies, I pretty
much knew she wasn't going to survive
rabies. Yeah. But if you, if you are
diagnosed with rabies, then what happened?
What do you do? Um, you,
you die basically you die.
Yeah. Well, like what?
All of the time. Some of
the time, all of the time.
It's a really deadly disease in terms of
the percentage of people who come down
with the symptoms of rabies, um, who die.
It is the deadliest disease in
the world. The deadliest, yeah.
Here's the bottom line. If we say there
are 55,000 cases of babies a year,
then you also have 55,000
rabies deaths a year.
Meaning it's a a hundred percent fatal.
Yeah. And by the way, this is Monica,
Monica Murphy. I'm a public
health veterinarian. And
this is bill bill Wassick.
Uh,
I'm a senior editor at wired magazine
and they wrote a book called Rabbit where
they trace the history of rabies
all the way back to the beginning.
There are references to rabies going back
as far as we have human writing in the
Samarian literature in
the Acadian literature.
So for thousands of years we have been
throwing everything and anything we can
think of at this disease and
failing. I mean that one like real,
I mean from the star, you see these
very, very weird cures. Desperate.
For example, in Roman and Greek times,
if you're a gene and you got bit by a bat,
you might've tried eating a Cox
brain goose grease mixed with honey,
the flesh of a mad dogs, salted
skin or old slough of a serpent,
a cloud from a swallow's
nest applied with vinegar,
and then we have the Dung of red poultry
provided it as if a red color is very
useful. If those didn't work,
you could pull out the feathers from
around the live rooster's anus and apply
the anus to the bite wounds on the theory
that said anus would suck the poison
up out of the wound. Wait a second.
How would a rooster's anus cure ever
catch on in the first place? I mean,
it wouldn't work. Well, yeah,
but if you think about it,
not every rabid dog or bat bite is
actually gonna transfer the virus in the
sense that you know, the, the saliva
just will fail to get the virus.
Where it needs to be is every so often
the healer is going to come along with
his rooster's anus and you know,
put it on your wound and sure
enough it works. Case closed.
We have our, our rabies cure. Ah,
so you're saying that plenty's list is
a lot of lucky accidents by sorcerers?
Yeah. I think that lucky accidents were
kind of probably what kept some of these
things kicking around in long enough to
become accepted. Well what do we know?
But rabies for real and what do we
actually know about the disease?
I mean not much. We know
it's a very unusual virus.
The way a typical virus travels
is it has a port of entry.
It replicates locally. It makes it into
the bloodstream. It circulates widely.
It finds its target tissues and then it
replicates exactly. So you get a wound,
it gets infected, that goes
into the blood. But rabies,
it enters the body at the bite
wound site. Say, in Gina's case,
the tip of her finger,
it binds to a nerve right
there to a particular receptor
and then crawls its way
up the nervous system, one
to two centimeters per day.
That's right to attack the brain.
It literally grabs onto the nerve and
climbs up. It's like hand over hand.
Might take a few days, go the length
of a finger maybe three weeks ago,
the length of an entire arm.
It's during that slow climb that we can
administer vaccine and help the body
mountain immune response.
If you give a person the vaccine
before they see symptoms,
while the virus is still
climbing its way up to the brain,
they should be okay, but once the
infection has taken root in the brain
[inaudible],
then it's too late for vaccination.
The moment you have a
twitchy finger at the moment,
you have like the slightest
flu like symptoms,
which will later progress into rabies.
That's the moment that you know
you're going to die of that disease.
What does the virus do when
it gets to the brain? Well,
it's very much not known specifically
what happens in the brain.
It might start shutting parts of your
brain down in about 30% of the cases,
the muscles might start
to kind of get paralyzed.
That's called paralytic rabies.
Eventually their entire body will get
paralyzed and they might just slump into a
coma or more often it's that that
cliche of the rabies death is,
is what actually happens where people
have these like spasms of rage.
[inaudible].
There are videos online where you can
see people in this room. Yeah. Youtube,
I find them im impossible to watch
[inaudible]
you know, just screaming and
writhing and convulsions.
[inaudible]
and from the viruses perspective,
it's trying to drive its host to be more
aggressive so that bites somebody else
and spreads more virus. Oh.
The other thing that is,
I find really perverse is that they
will get this fear of water or really
powerful fear of water. The human
victim of rabies tries to drink,
wants to drink,
but then they'll bring the cup to their
hands and digital shake and overflow the
muscles in their throat seize up
the gag reflex and they can't.
They can't drink water. Yeah.
You can imagine though, again,
from the viruses perspective,
why that would be advantageous.
You are trying to transmit
virus through biting.
So an animal who can't swallow his,
his virus filled saliva, you're
going to be like a loaded gun. Right?
And eventually after a few
days in these late stages,
person might lapse into a
coma, have a heart attack.
There's really any number of ways
you could die. That sounds
awful. In a, it was a,
it was.
So when the official results came back
and Rodney took Gina's mom and dad and in
John Keasy into a room and yeah,
told them we're sorry,
but she has rabies and it's
definitely too late for the vaccine.
John and I both started crying, you know,
is there anything that can be
done? And one of the doctors said,
there's nothing we can do. I can either
put her in a dark room and let her die.
You can take her home and
let her die and we're just,
this can't be happening. They
said, uh, what else do you got?
They said, well, we can do standard sense
of care. Well, does that work? Well?
No. What else do you have? And
then Dr Willoughby said, OK, well,
well, I do have an idea.
I'd like to try this.
I don't even know what he called
it. Okay. So the night before,
while they were waiting for the test
results, hoping it wasn't rabies,
Rodney started calling
around, you know, I,
I should call the CDC asking if there
was anything that was unpublished but
promising they say no. And then I
essentially headed to the library.
And what I did is I
pulled a, I don't know,
about 20 years with the case reports,
started readings on a pretty hopeless,
but,
but he does notice one thing he sees
mentioned in this one kind of obscure
paper. I read one article that said, well,
this might be to sort of neurotransmission
yet maybe what's happening in the
brain during rabies is something
called excited, toxicity.
Excited, excited, toxicity.
CYTO toxicity. Yeah.
It sounds exciting and maybe toxic.
What is it? Well, excited toxicity.
And this is, this is tricky stuff.
Um, and it's controversial. Yeah.
Is this the kind of thing that
actually makes rabies or researchers at
conferences get into fights with each
other? Here's the basic idea. Um,
you might think that, uh,
a brain infection just
physically destroys the brain.
Yeah. But under this theory, the
brain isn't physically destroyed.
It's just that the neurons themselves are
getting overstimulated overexcited and
then that part of the brain is disrupted
and it all just kind of shuts down.
Just making it impossible for
the brain to function properly.
And so the sort of life
sustaining functions of the brain,
like breathing and you
know, circulating blood,
they stopped working because the neurons
that control them are just overwhelmed.
Right. In other words, [inaudible]
doesn't destroy the brain.
It disrupts the brain.
The brain itself is spared. So
it's like a software problem,
not a hardware problem. Yeah.
And what Rodney read is that people had
died of rabies and in the autopsy their
brains looked totally fine.
Entirely normal. Moreover,
the virus was gone. You couldn't even
detect the rabies virus in their brain.
Brain no longer had rabies
in it. Really? Yeah.
It was like there was no weapon at the
scene of the crime. So that was my clue.
What that suggested to Rodney is that
the immune system does eventually turn on
right and it kicks in and it
starts fighting the disease.
But it just gets there too late. So
the immune system had all the tools,
but essentially this virus beat
your immune system to the punch.
It would kill you faster
than immune response could
eradicate it cause the virus
moves what more quickly than
the immune system? Way Faster.
And to me it was like,
well you know the solution
there is obvious and if he
could buy Jeanna's immune
system some time, enough time,
you could clear the brain and the brain
would not be damaged. She might survive.
So what he suggest to Anne is
that he put Jeanna into a coma,
put her into a coma,
induced the coma. And if,
if an anesthesiologist is controlling
routine brainstem activities like
breathing circulation,
then no matter what the virus is
actually doing inside her brain,
he might be able to keep her alive
long enough for the immune
system. Make a response,
which would take normally
about seven to 10 days.
And this is still kind of a guess. This
is, this is entirely improvised. Yeah.
And lots of things can go
wrong and when they go wrong,
they typically go wrong badly.
He knows there's a huge risk that she's
going to end up being brain dead or
maybe locked in.
And that's worse than death,
I think in everybody's eyes.
Were you nervous about the cost?
Like he said she could end up being
a vegetable just like she cried.
I don't think I thought that
far ahead. I thought more of um,
let's just keep her alive,
get the disease out of her.
So they put Jeanna into a coma.
[inaudible]
Rodney figures, we'll give her a
week and then we'll check to see
if she has an immune response. Um,
and once they had her hooked up,
so with the coma, she had, uh,
the pole with all the Ivy Stefan and
the different medications and stuff and
stays with Gina in the hospital room
and spends her time praying and calling
people and asking them to pray.
And she repeated this one prayer,
psalm 91 over and over again.
It talks about, you know,
basically the devil not getting a hold
of you. He is my refuge and my fortress,
my god in whom I trust.
Surely He will save you from the Fowler's
snare and from the deadly pestilence.
And so we were just waiting,
we'll cover you with his feathers
waiting and under his wings you will find
refuge.
It was probably the most uncomfortable
feeling I've ever had in medicine.
Seven days in, they sample her
spinal fluid, send it in for testing,
and then they get the results
which say, oh, her antibody responses,
uh, is then and going up, uh,
immune system is working. Yeah,
it was working in, in fact,
we now have rabies antibody and we had
a fair amount of it and it was in the
spinal fluid is the meaning
of this around the brain.
And so essentially plan
worked. So we said, well, okay,
let's start waking her up.
But as they're waking her up,
she has a fever and they couldn't
figure out what was causing the fever.
So they put her back under for another
week and then finally they start to wake
her up again. And she
gradually, you know, woke up,
the brand activity looked
great and she had nice pupils,
but physically she did not move a muscle.
[inaudible]
it pins her, they'd poke her.
She had no movement anywhere
other than her pupils. So,
so she was responding to
light light. That's it.
And this was the one thing
that Rodney was most afraid of,
that
Gina was a lock in
[inaudible]
essentially locked inside
this box of a body.
And it was the worst day of my life
because it looked like she would progress
survive and we'd actually done worse
than death. And as Rodney
drove back and forth from work
[inaudible]
he kept repeating this one prayer. Jesus
Christ, son of God, have mercy on me.
A poor center. Jesus Christ,
son of God, have mercy on me,
a poor center. Jesus Christ, son of God,
have mercy on me for center. And then,
um, about two days later,
Rodney's in the hospital and he's
looking over Gina's charts. Yeah,
just checking. Hello Sam. Uh,
and another doctor was finishing up her
shift and she comes over to Rodney said,
oh, did you know that she had
reflexes today? And I said, no.
[inaudible]
Rodney grabs the reflex hammer and
then sure enough she had knee reflexes.
The next day
her eyes started flooding a little bit.
Within a week she was back for a
couple of weeks after I woke up.
I still have no memory.
This is gene and Keasy the first person
to survive rabies without the vaccine.
Um, my first memory was
actually Thanksgiving Day,
a couple of weeks after she woke
up from the coma back in 2004. Um,
I just remember being
with my family and um,
um, playing board games with my brothers
and then just them being there and then
going down to the cafeteria for dinner,
having fish. I remember we had to fish.
How long was she in the
hospital? For? About two months.
I had to learn how to stand and
then Norwalk, um, turn around,
move my toes. Um, I was really
after reviews, you know,
a newborn baby who couldn't do anything.
And then I had to really learn
that all. Do you remember that?
Do you remember that feeling? Yeah,
I mentally I was there, you know,
mentally I knew how to do stuff,
but my body wouldn't cooperate
with what I want it to do.
And it was frustrating and it definitely
took a toll on me psychologically.
You know, I'm still recovering. I'm
not completely back. Stuff like,
like balance and um, I can't, you know,
run normally she can't
play volleyball anymore,
but she finished high
school, went to college.
I graduated with a degree in just general
biology and now Gina is really into
bets. She's a bat lover. Yeah. If I
ever go down to the zoo, you know,
they always pay,
let me go behind and in with the baths
and I can pet them and stuff. Yeah,
I'll feed them all. Panam I've been
going to Belfast vols here in Wisconsin,
so I have no fear of bets.
That would be the last person I would
expect to go to a bat festival. Oh,
this girl is this scene,
that's all she is the poster child
for what became known as the Milwaukee
Protocol. That's the name of Rodney's,
a thing that he did with her. Yeah.
I mean this has been tried. Again,
this has been tried all around the
world by different people and different
versions of it, but it's been tried
to around 30 times with what result.
So everything I'm about to say forward,
there's debate about every single
little bit of it, but he says, uh,
five survivors. Five survivor. Yeah.
Out of how many people of about 30
people, which on the one hand is,
that seems like a, a terrible,
you know, percentage, uh,
for a treatment for a disease. Five
out of 30. But on the other hand,
this is rabies and you know,
for all of human history
it was zero out of 30. Um,
was there anything about
five that separates them
from the others? Well, this,
this, this brings us to, uh, the,
the, the really murky territory.
You know, rapey suspend one of those,
just really interesting pathogens to me.
The more you think you know about it,
the more you don't know about
it. This is Amy, Dr. Amy Gilbert.
I'm a research biologist at the National
Wildlife Research Center here in Fort
Collins.
So this gets to your question,
Robert. A couple of years ago,
Amy actually went to study rabies in Peru.
Oh,
with this guy [inaudible] the
physician, but professional,
just so happen. Sergio is also from Peru.
I was born in Lima and he now works
as an epidemiologist at the CDC.
So going to, but in 2010 they
traveled deep into the Amazon jungle.
First one limo will have to travel
to Tarapoto on Fronterra Potawatomi.
We're talking remote hours from
[inaudible] was to Sanlorenzo on deploy.
They're looking for,
well they were studying bat born
diseases and in that part of the world,
people have a lot of contact with
vampire paths. So we choose two towns,
Trina Kutcha and Santa Marta.
So they arrive and have a pretty lengthy
discussion with the community leaders,
explain what they're up to and go
door to door, household to household.
We shit each house and talk
with one member of the family.
And they'll ask, you know, have you
been bit by a Vamp [inaudible] Bat?
Have you had any illnesses
than they take a blood sample.
And what they found is basically
rabies front page news,
11%, um, of the blood sample
bells that were tested,
seven people out of 63 had what we
call evidence of virus neutralizing
antibodies. They had rabies
antibodies in their blood.
Uh, okay.
Well you know how I mentioned
that sometimes the body
will mount a response to
rabies but it's just too late. Yeah.
So you might see those antibodies,
but only when somebody's dying. Right.
And these people in Peru,
they had the antibodies but we didn't
have any evidence there was any
neurological disease in any of the
cases. They didn't seem to have rabies,
but we're really very surprised. I'm
sorry. Why? Well, think about it.
The only way they could have gotten
those antibodies in their blood was by
contact. In some points with the virus,
they'd come into contact with
rabies and yet they were fine.
It was almost as if they
were immune to rabies. Huh?
Well, I had,
Amy won't use that word immune because
the data are sort of inconclusive as to
whether there was any [inaudible]
the tree into the brain,
like they didn't know if the virus
made it all the way into these people's
brains. And so did they come down
with full-blown rabies or not?
They don't know. But it's possible
that these people are special.
Some people even argue that there are
special individuals who are able to
survive rabies and not just in Peru.
Monica told me about another case.
He, Texas wild child, your
baby's case laboratory confirmed.
Um, a girl in Texas, 17 year
old girl, I've run away,
she shows up in 2009 at a hospital
in Houston. She has a headache.
Her neck hurts and she's really agitated.
They confirmed that it was rabies,
but she didn't receive the Milwaukee
Protocol or any critical care measures as
far as we know. They just
figured she would die.
[inaudible]
but then three weeks later this
girl went on, you know, to,
to walk out of the hospital. She
just got better. No drugs, no coma,
nothing on her own. Huh. Wow.
[inaudible]
and this actually brings us back to Gina.
She's pretty close to normal because
at the point when she arrived at the
hospital to see Rodney, he asked,
she was diagnosed as having small
amounts of antibody in hers.
She already had antibody in her
blood. Like those people in Peru.
She did not have recoverable virus.
We could not isolate virus from her,
which is unusual. It does seem that she
is immunologically special. In fact,
if you look at all of the people who
have gotten the Milwaukee Protocol and
survived, they all have that
profile. Like the girl in Texas,
like precious Reynolds,
that's another girl who got the
Milwaukee Protocol and survived.
They have had similar elaborate
comeback though. Those patients,
you know, have, have extraordinary
lab work and extraordinary outcomes.
And so some researchers
in Canada and Thailand,
I've argued that Rodney's protocol
actually had very little effect,
nothing to do with, and
[inaudible] surviving.
They would say she survived despite
Dr Willoughby's treatment rather than,
because I've talked to
[inaudible] treatment. Oh.
So they're accusing him of basically
pulling a rooster's anus kind of number.
Uh, I don't think they would. You
know, really put it that way. Exactly.
[inaudible]
they say that the Milwaukee Protocol
should be discontinued and that we
shouldn't be wasting time
and money on it. You know,
they in bank are acutely aware of the
fact that to do one Milwaukee Protocol
case, you could vaccinate,
I think it was all of the kids in
Bangkok preventatively against rabies,
tens of thousands of slum kids in Bangkok
could be preventatively vaccinated
against rabies. So these
credits would say, you know,
give people a vaccines but don't induce
the coma and don't use these untested
drugs that Rodney administers.
And if somebody comes in with an
advanced case of rabies, well,
unless you have evidence that they're
one of these immunologically special
people, you just need to accept
the fact that they're going to die.
I think. No calling not to do
anything. I will definitely disagree.
We'll have to do something.
According to Sergio,
the idea that Rodney somehow just got
incredibly lucky when he was treating
Gina. Geasey does very unlikely.
Gina was basically at death's door.
And there are some things might not be
fully understanding you in that use case.
But it was obvious that itchy
was no given this alternative.
She might not have survived.
And you could argue that if Jean is part
of this immunologically special group
of people who can just survive
rabies without the vaccine,
and how come nobody did
before Rodney came along?
You know, this is really not
science. This is right now,
storytelling does something
right, but we still don't know.
And we won't know until we figure out
which parts work and don't work. You know,
for now, Rodney's for us to evaluate
and try to improve the protocol.
Just one patient at a time without
the funding or research that he wants.
So you know, no clinical trials,
no animal models. So we're,
we're left learning the hard way, which
is an awful way to learn. But he says,
you can't just give up hope. You know,
in the early days of cancer treatment,
they weren't having any success,
but they didn't just stop.
And I've seen treatments for cancer
evolve over my professional career from
being 0% survival to being 85% survival.
And now he puts the success rate of
his protocol at about 20% that's a lot
better than zero. And it could go up,
might not go up. It's true. So
if you're a doctor now though,
and a kid comes into the
hospital, hasn't had the vaccine,
has a full blown case of
rabies, what do you do?
Do you just derp your hands say
sorry. It's not going to make it.
Do you check and see if
maybe he's immunologically
special, put him in Tacoma.
You put him into a coma that you
don't know who's going to work,
whatever the case.
You've actually gotta be glad that Rodney
gave Gina shot because whether or not
you think that he saved her
life or she saved her own life,
the fact is that at least now we know
that rabies isn't quite the killer that we
once thought it was. He took
it off of its throne of death.
Even if you know, just a little bit.
And when we say, you know,
maybe he's just coming off,
it's a hundred percent thrown it,
it's, you know, down to 99.999,
you know, like, it's, it might, it
might be that it was never quite on
that throne. Exactly. Ever. Right.
[inaudible]
all right. Well, uh, we've certainly
clear things up. Thank you, Tim. Yeah,
sure thing. Thanks also to Ashvin
Shaw for research help and, uh,
you guys for listening.